when it comes to gain of function
research when it comes to heart attack
guns when it comes to microwave weapons
um can we admit that this is getting a
little bit out of hand that this is a
little bit crazy especially with the
we need the aliens especially with the
latest allegations
from the united states accusing china of
literally
gene splicing and manipulating human
beings to be super soldiers dude it's
completely out of hand
yes i mean what the what well this is an
accusation from an anonymous u.s intel
source which should be questioned to the
highest
extent but it wouldn't surprise me if
china or even the united states
at this point was doing something to
create super soldiers probably corporate
the corporate power is really getting
out of
this is nuts yes check this story out
china conducting biological tests to
create super soldiers
us spy chief says that's recent
intelligence director john ratcliffe
claims human testing
aims to develop super soldiers with
biologically enhanced capabilities
yeah two days ago the article came from
an anonymous source now i guess he's
kind of guardian with it yeah the
guardian
this is you want to play look look look
i keep saying news guard certified i say
it
because we're talking about aliens and
i know someone from media matters is
sitting there going like ooh they're
writing it all down
it's the guardian the guardian says that
china's
it's john ratcliffe is saying this check
this out writing in the wall street
journal
ratcliffe said quote the intelligence is
clear beijing intends to dominate the us
and the rest of the planet economically
militarily and technologically many of
china's major public initiatives and
prominent companies
offer only a layer of camouflage to the
activities of the chinese communist
party
ratcliffe said china had gone to
extraordinary lengths to achieve its
goal
quote u.s intelligence shows that china
has been conducting
has even conducted human testing on
members of the people's liberation
army in hope of developing soldiers with
biologically enhanced capabilities
there are no ethical boundaries to
beijing's pursuit of power
remember just a year ago we learned that
a rogue scientist was genetically
altering babies and they arrested him
and he did actually yeah check this out
he's probably working for the u.s
government about a year ago
no no no i got i got a different thought
chinese scientists who edited babies
genes jailed for three years
two theories one they saw what he was
doing and they said
i want your research we want to
weaponize it two
he was a scientist who was familiar with
their research and went rogue and was
using it and they were like
stop don't let don't let people find out
what you're drawing too much attention
to what we're doing with these programs
if this doesn't show you that china is
preparing for war
i don't know what other sign you need to
see it's right there on the wall
i mean when you look at their the you
know all the money that they're spending
literally trying to communicate with
aliens
building up their entire naval fleet
building up
military man-made islands microwaving
soldiers on the border of
india and stealing us military
technology that they've been getting
from israel that's another thing that
i don't know if you want to look up
lydia but israel many times has given
out
intelligence secrets from the united
states and sold it
to china there was even an israeli
defense minister that had to resign
in a major controversy because china was
able to get their hands on advanced usa
listen listen we have the story about
india and china the microwave weapons so
india is disputing the claim that china
routed their troops with microwave
blaster
i bel i don't i don't know how to
believe but i kind of believed the
microwave initial reports was that
indians felt like they were
being lit up in fire from the inside and
then they had to run away because the
pain was excruciating
let's talk about what's going on with
these super soldiers like what exactly
are they doing what
because listen listen we got all this
sci-fi we got all these movies you got
things like uh have you have you watched
the boys
no have you seen the boys yeah awesome
show and it's basically
spoiler alert for those that haven't
seen the second season are
having if look it's it's been out for a
while now so you know it's you have no
blame but yourself you haven't watched
it homeland nazi scientists
escaped to the u.s and they developed a
super soldier serum that gives people
superpowers but mostly only works in
babies it's most stable in babies
and they're trying to figure out how to
get it into people and they've kind of
figured it out
so in this show people can fly and they
can shoot laser beams and they heal and
they're invulnerable
clearly gene editing can't do that but
what if they made someone have the
maximum jump height
you've heard of a
they could take the sperm from the guy
the egg from the mom
and they could go to a laboratory that
literally picks out the best combination
where you could select the height right
the genetic disposition of your
of your of your child so it's already
happening so to think that this is not
happening on a military level where
they're taking the best elite special
forces green beret guys and taking their
dna
and duplicating it to match with the
best of the best when it comes to
fighting and meaning and killing other
people
you'd be killing you'd be kidding
yourself there's been many movies about
this that were fictional
where the guy finally gets some
consciousness this super soldier that's
created finally starts fighting back
against the empire and takes them down
because they made him too strong
and we could hope for that but life is
not a movie
and this is absolutely terrifying that
there's super soldiers out there
that have been genetically put together
you want to know why that could be
to be assassins you want to know it's a
very serious problem yeah obviously
okay first of all what they're going to
be doing is likely programming
individuals
this is this is this is the guardian
john radcliffe like this is being
reported okay
they can't just take a random person
who's loyal to the people's liberation
army and say we're gonna you know inject
you with the serum it's gonna change
your dna or something they're gene
editing babies
and probably people to a certain degree
like adults but babies is the easiest
way to do it they'll grow into it
they're probably then raising these kids
in special conditions and training them
to be super soldiers now
here's the problem with genetic
engineering if that escapes into the
human gene pool
and you don't know what those genes will
do in the long run you could taint the
entire human gene pool with some failing
genome and then in 50 to 100 years
it's this this genes become widespread
in most populations
and then everyone gets a debilitating
disease and dies coronavirus
no i'm not talking about viruses i'm
talking about were they working on a
this is not a virus
you're talking about being in a lab
using a virus you can use viruses yeah
but
you're you're totally derailing off of
everything i'm talking about i'm
questioning if that's a bible no they
use the genes gene editing is e coli
they don't use coronavirus for this
what i'm saying is that when we
genetically engineer crops yeah you can
use viruses to edit genes
yes e coli not coronavirus you don't
know that
i literally i'm talking what yes they do
gene editing by using e coli to
manipulate uh
the genetic structure or something like
that i don't know there was a big green
color as a bacteria but you brought
up you brought up a very good point
because again people are playing
uh you know like like their gods they're
they're essentially
coming up with these powers that they're
going to be using for the quote greater
good because if you're in china the
greater good is to create super soldiers
to fight the bad americans
and the americans are being told the
same thing we need to create probably
super soldiers i wouldn't
i wouldn't doubt that this project is
being done on
some kind of offshoot uh contractor that
doesn't face any liability or
accountability like a government agency
and when we look at
the defense department they are becoming
more and more dependent on doing a lot
of their experiments
and a lot of their very borderline
unethical activities
through private companies and third
parties that again
you can't get any records of what
they're actually doing so and
here's what i'm saying we've we've seen
select a gene editing
in many different crops and then there's
been accusations for a long time that
these companies
will drive up to a farm and chuck seeds
into the field
so that the gene mixes with all other
crops and then they can copyright it
or they they they have centos right
monsanto has intellectual property
ownership over the genome
then they'll they sow the seeds
everywhere so that every plant in these
farms
you know interbreeds with them and then
they come back later take a sample and
say aha you're using our proprietary
technology you owe us money
this eventually destroys the existence
of the original
crop so i was reading something i don't
know you have to uh those listening
factors me on this one i was reading
there used to be like you know
hundreds of different kinds of apples
and now there's only like a small
handful of varieties there's a bunch of
different kinds of potatoes and now we
only have a small
you know amount of varieties because we
consume and deplete one
and then favor another and replace it so
like you'll go and you'll see like a
certain potato you'll eat it and say
well this one's better and you'll plant
that one instead
if they're editing human beings and then
let's say in 20 years they abandoned the
program
and now these edited human beings are
just wandering around and like i don't
know and i started having families and
kids
how long until those edited genes exist
across the world especially if they're
like enticing humans like faster more
attractive then their genes are going to
spread faster naturally but what if
they're also bred to be more
vicious and not to have that empath
empathetic response because they're
supposed to be killing machines
what if the goal is to create a super
soldier which means they can't hesitate
when killing for any reason
and then you get these people start
having kids and also you've got about
just
generations of socio i think it's gonna
happen i mean i just think it's like
the fallout future of you got the
mutants and you have the cyborgs and
like some people have like genetic legs
that you're genetically altered to run
faster some people have cybernetic
implants that let them run faster
some people have genetic eye and their
eyes are genetically so they can see 10
times further some people have
cybernetic
you know contact lenses so they can see
10 times further while trillions of
dollars is being spent on this madness
there's still people in flint who can't
get clean drinking water
i mean for free are you kidding me and i
think
you know this is important to talk about
and to kind of
theorize because this is a reality and
there is a big possibility that these
genetically modified super soldiers
already exist
genetic modification already happens to
our food and there's this famous quote
by albert einstein that said
world war iv would be fought with sticks
and stones
and to me uh sorry world war five would
be fought with sticks and stones i don't
know what world war ii
let me read the quote let me hear the
question i do not know with what weapons
world war three will be fought
but world war iv will be bought fought
with sticks and stones
i love that guy and i think that's
absolutely true with the scale
of military advancement and technology
that we have come to
that already is very difficult for human
beings to
to understand and to deal with i mean
human beings already are dealing
with a massive psychological negative
effect because of the internet
there's no denying the psychological
downtroddeness of humanity
mainly because of these little dopamine
devices that have been gamified
by special interests that literally run
our entire lives now so
uh i can tell you that world war iv will
not be fought with sticks and stones
i can tell you that we are in it right
now and it is fifth generation warfare
it is information and propaganda
control of opinions so this is something
i've been saying for quite some time and
i didn't make it up there's actually
several
research papers published on the matter
what is the goal of war and we've talked
about this right
you want to assert control over a group
of people gain access to resources or
just you know have them work on your
behalf for some reason
or maybe even prevent a potential
conflict in the past the easiest way to
get it done
was when all else fails you point a gun
at them and say do it or else
and you you you suppress them and you
get rid of the ruling class you get rid
of the officers the professors any
professionals in the society they're
just
gone but you come in with force you come
in with guns and blazes
yeah just like my people saw world war
ii yeah with world war ii with germany
and of course the ussr they took over
took anyone influential and they just
you know mandated everything to be done
we are we are in the information age
there's no reason to do any of that when
you can
convince people to bow for you to give
up
to destroy their own economies and look
at what's happening in the us right now
if i had to make a bet if someone came
to me and said would you be willing to
place a substantial wager on
the us is under attack through
propaganda and influence campaign
so the country destroys itself i would
say yes i believe yeah it's weird to
think
of it as an attack that's i think the
dissonance that people are facing
you know because the scary aspect of
this is when you see
the amount of control that china has on
hollywood
yup that should absolutely terrify you
when you see i think there was even a
recent movie
that was just totally banned in china
because of one little small phrase and
then that movie is going to lose out on
a ton of revenue
that a whole bunch of hollywood
executives that literally are compared
to satanists
that's what hollywood executives are
compared to because they would sell
their soul
or just shaking at the boots because of
how much money and how much profit they
could be getting
and when you look at that just one small
example of our everyday lives it should
terrify you
oh yeah we had the nba we had the famous
you know basketball players coming out
and saying leave china alone we had the
hearthstone uh game players had free
hong kong
we have in this country a large group of
powerful and influential people who have
already sworn capitalistic allegiance
to the chinese communist party no joke
no exaggeration
yeah well this is why also the central
intelligence agency from its inception
always swooned hollywood producers
actors to be a part of its official
psychological programs and its official
agency since of course
the cia also has a very big involvement
in hollywood and they know
culture movies music everything that we
do when we
fifth generational warfare when we don't
try to think and we just try to enjoy
ourselves as being used and weaponized
in a way for a particular outcome that
we don't even
know about whether it's subliminal
messaging or just outright propaganda or
disinformation or psychological warfare
we have to understand we're in the
middle of it right now there's a major
war happening
there's a lot of lives being lost
there's a lot of people
killing themselves when they don't need
to be killing themselves there's a lot
of people
driven into making mistakes with their
lives because they see rich and famous
people doing it
and they're like i could do that too i
should take this
pill or this narcotic or i should be a
degenerate
this way as well the culture and how
it's being usurped so people become
their own worst enemies
is something to really highlight and to
look at because if you look at
what's been coming out in the tv shows
and the movies in the mainstream media
it's all against families it's all
against
breaking people apart making sure you
fight each other making sure you hate
each other on the micro
difference that you could even find in a
human being
so that's where we're at right now yes
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you